this is a production of Cornell
University thank you Andrew for that
wonderful introduction we'll get to the
arm wrestling thing here in a second
thank you to the organizers of the
seminar series for allowing me to come
and give this talk today and thank you
for all of you coming out and giving me
your time to come listen to what we've
been working on for the last eight years
on RNA modifications and I'll start at
the very beginning of my lab to give you
some perspective
um and start there my one lesson to you
based on my introduction from Andrew is
do not arm wrestle ever it is extremely
bad and this would be why I'm retired
it's because I have a metal plate
running from the top all the way down to
the Elbow of my humorous and I cracked
that humorous arm wrestling on Christmas
day with my wife's
family and I never get to live that
story down because we spend every
Christmas with my wife's family and they
remind me of it every year when it
happened five years ago and I also have
that Nifty scar anyway so from there now
you know my story don't arm wrestle um
I'll try and tell undergraduates a few
other stories as we go along here but
what I am going to talk to you about I
don't know why this is doing this um if
this is driving people nuts it might
drive me nuts we'll see let's let's
let's try to get through it okay um but
what I'm going to talk to you guys about
is R any modifications how they affect
posttranscriptional regulation
oh thank you it's because my
hands okay anyway how they AFF post
transcription Rel regulation to affect
various stress responses and that's
where I'm going to spend most of my time
um in today's talk but before we get
there I just want to remind you what
posttranscriptional regulation means and
it means this very busy slide right here
which is all the processes that an RNA
has to go through after transcription
makes it or actually while transcription
is making it including capping splicing
poen modification which is where I'm
going to spend most of my time talking
about today folding because we have
spent some work on this as well and then
how all of these new features of the RNA
molecule affect this very very important
decision here which is whether to
translate and whether to degrade and
when we should degrade and we spend a
lot of time thinking about this
transition and how modifications affect
that and that's really where I'm going
to be spending most of my time talking
about today I do have to say that when I
started my lab a number of years ago we
were interested really in looking at
three features of the RNA molecule
itself what the RNA looks like how it
folds secondary structure which is what
you can see here so this RNA region
knows how to fold based on int molecular
base pairing interactions between this
region and this region leaving this
region single stranded and we developed
protocols to look at this um and then
went through and thought okay well we're
very interested in looking at what an
RNA looks like but in addition to how it
folds it also has a c of proteins that
interact with it throughout its life
cycle from that transcription through
capping through folding and then through
this ultimate decision here and these
proteins are known as AR binding
proteins and so we sat down and we spent
a bunch of time thinking could we
develop an approach to look at secondary
structure and protein binding all at the
same time and the answer to that
question was yes because otherwise I
wouldn't have said that and we developed
this approach here that we call PIP seek
whereby you can treat with structure
specific RI ribonucleases with those
proteins still there or after a light DN
and degradation of those proteins and so
we can use these libraries to look at
secondary structure and we can look at
these libraries to take an Arna Centric
view of every region of an RNA that's
Bound by a protein throughout its life
cycle based on what proteins are bound
with the rnas and the various kind of
conglomeration of the collection of rnas
and a collection of tissue we can get a
snapshot of kind of all of its RNA
binding domains and we've used that
approach to look at secondary structure
in the rabbit off nucleus and also to go
through and find new Regulators sorry
new Regulators of root hair cell
development and a number of other
different questions and I'm going to
tell you if I get to it at the end here
we're starting to look at nanapur to
look at at modification in newly
transcribing mrnas and we're also going
to try and get back into the structure
game to also look at co-transcriptional
wholey and how modifications affect that
but I might not get to that part of my
talk today um what I am going to spend
most of my talk about focusing on today
is that third feature of the RNA
molecules themselves so we have talked
about folding not going to talk about it
anymore well I'm going to briefly talk
about it here in a second we've talked
about RNA binding proteins but rnas can
also increase their coating capacity
through chemical moities that can be
added to the ends including the
canonical cap which is an m7g as well as
polyadenylation and how long these tails
are can kind of dictate how stable an AR
is and there's lots of internal
modifications that can occur in specific
regions either the CDs the five Prim utr
the three prime utr and what I'm going
to be focusing on today is this
modification itself m6a and I'm also
going to be talking about this
non-canonical cap molecule here this mad
cap and in fact I'm going to start at
the five Prime and work to the three
prime when we start talking about um R
modifications we'll get to there that
here in a second but I also just need to
show you that I'm going to talk mostly
about two RNA modifications but there's
about 153 modifications that we know of
that occur on rnas we know this mostly
because they occur on trnas and Ras
which are easy to extract easy to
masspec and easy to get at but what we
are finding is many of these also do.
mrnas so figuring out their
functionality in mrnas obviously for you
graduate students there's still a lot of
work to be done in this field um and in
fact you might even be able to select
your own modification and go work on
that in the future so keep keep that in
mind right there's still a lot of room
um in this area of research for many
many many types of researchers to
working on but like I said what I'm
going to focus on quickly is our recent
work on this non-canonical cap this mad
cap that can we find can replace the M7
gcap many times and it can specifically
on
specific cohorts of transcripts replace
this cap to affect specific
physiological processes I'll show you
our evidence for me being able to say
that here in a second so please remember
if you remember nothing else from my
talk today please remember this slide
and that you this is what a mature mRNA
looks like it has a five Prime cap a
five prime utr a coding region which
most of us think about this is where the
protein is encoded a three prime utr and
a poly tail what I can tell you is this
is genomically encoded this is
genomically encoded this is genomically
encoded and both of these are
added during transcription and
posttranscriptionally and in fact it's
the addition of the poly tale that
terminates transcription UK carots
because it's the cleavage factor that
sets the end of the three prime utr to
start polyad dentil it basically
terminates transcription of that
transcript um in in UK carotic organisms
and so if you just want to know what the
chemical structure actually looks like
here here's your um stick and stick in
and ball model here and you can see that
this is this is actually attached this
canonical pack the seven methyl
guanosine is attached to this phosphate
phosphate Bridge whereby it's the alpha
phosphate from the 7
that actually attaches to the beta
phosphate at the five Prime end of the
MRNA and so you still have a
triphosphate but it's protected even
more by the seven methyl guanosine and
this methylation event is actually put
on later and most likely is involved in
self versus non-self and we are getting
quite interested in this type of
methylation event here too but I'm not
going to be able to talk about that
today but we've also found we and others
we weren't the first to discover that
this modification could be added to
mrnas in fact bacterial scientists are
people working on bacteria as their
model organism found in fact that this
NAD RNA the nicotin adamine dinucleotide
molecule and I that's the last time I'm
going to say that because I said it
perfectly and I feel very good about
myself because usually I say it
completely wrong and I'm feeling very
good so we're just going to call it NAD
from now on okay um NAD this NAD
molecule can now be added we found the
five Prime end of mrnas in bacteria we
know how it's added so because I know
I'm going to get this question so I'm
just going to answer it now no we do not
know when or how this molecule is added
um in fact this is something that I we
are actively looking at right because we
want to be able to control the addition
of this because we find that it's an
incredibly powerful po transcriptional
regulator and I'll show you evidence for
that here in a second but we do not know
how this is added in UK
carots okay there you
go so we don't so I would I would
venture to say yes this is something
we're very very interested in like how
does the overall metabolic pool affect
what modifications can be added right
methylation events if you are depleted
for it you're not going to methylate
your rnas anymore what I can tell you
because I cut this part out of this talk
is we found if you trap this on the end
of an RNA molecule the plants get Inc
very very very very unhappy okay so if
we inhibit the ability of the plant to
make to get rid of this this this this
from the end of its mrnas using the
enzyme that normally does it which I'm
going to introduce to you here in a
second dxo1 so if we knock that out and
keep it on there plants will actually go
around that and start chopping those
mrnas into small rnas 21 to 24
nucleotides in size so what it looks
like in fact is for all of you small RNA
biogenesis the fici inad and people that
are interested in that it looks like
small biogenesis actually was an ancient
degr ation pathway that has been
co-opted now to make small functional
rnas but its first probably introduction
into UK carots was just to chop up rnas
and that was the first RNA that they had
and it broke it up into bigger pieces in
single nucleotides so then what happens
is if you keep this on there by knocking
out dx01 the dadder plants will go
through because they really want that
NAD back to get back in the the pool of
metabolites they'll just break it down
into small RNA thereby recycling through
additional means and if you not out the
ability to make small rnas then they
actually upregulate all the enzymes to
make NAD so I'm assuming that if you
have NAD deficiency something's going to
go and and you're not going to properly
regulate your transcripton so I'm going
to show you here in a second plants use
this to specifically destabilize pools
of rnas depending on where they are in
development and where they are in
responding to specific hormones and I'm
going to come to that here did I answer
your question well yeah okay great okay
so our first forray into this and of
course I can tell you this in a very
beautiful linear talk and you're like oh
gosh yes you are so brilliant you
thought of this and you guys just found
the mutant and then just went through
and characterized it as
poppycock this next little vignette I'm
going to talk to you guys about I
started as a brand new professor when I
read the first paper on this dading
enzyme it was called something else in
yeast but I went and found the
orthologue in plants and I worked on
this myself eight years ago
and it took us somebody else publishing
that this is in fact a dading enzyme and
then we went in and said okay well let's
make an approach where we can look at
nadca rnas and plants and then finally
we could put one two and two together to
figure out what the heck this enzyme
does in plants and what this Moy
actually is doing within transcriptomes
so then we could add to this body of
literature mainly because we had all of
this stuff laying around because we've
been working on this project for 10
years so graduate students don't give up
right never give up always remember your
data and just keep plugging away because
eventually something's going to help you
something's going to click and you're
going to end up getting a very nice
story a very nice publication out even
when the days look bad so what I'm just
telling you here is we developed an
approach to specifically pull down the
NAD related the thing the mrnas with
nads on their five Prime ends and then
we could clone and sequence those using
um um using aluminous sequencing and so
what I'm using this slide here is to
show you in fact that the nading of rnas
is very very specific between tissues so
if you look at the nated rnas and 10day
old seedlings and compare those to the
ones that we find in Wild type plants
here so these have all the functional
components of n adding the n and dading
the the transcripts you can see that
it's basically an entirely distinct pool
between these two tissues and what I'm
going to show you even if you treat with
Ava for a few hours we can find very
distinct pools and that's why we think
the addition of NAD and UK carots is not
done transcriptionally just by set down
by that first nucleotide but is in fact
an active process whereby you can
actually potentially remove the NAD and
recap or at least it's added as same
same as the cap in in UK carats where
it's an enzyme that add adds it to the
five Prime end during the process of
transcripting and so what you can see
down here and this was the enzyme that I
was getting at dx01 this is a dading
enzyme served from yeast to humans to
plants and when we knock it out we get
the expected phenotype when it comes to
n rnas specifically now we can find more
rnas in their nated form because it's
stabilized in that form like I told you
the plants don't like this mutation they
go through and they start turning these
mrnas into small Ras to get that mad
back so this is a very sick plant but we
use it as a tool def find those nated
rnas and to specifically stabilize them
and also to go and and and do some inter
biology
and so then what we also found I cut the
slide out here due to time constraints
but what we did was when we did these
Original Flower Bud sequencing we found
that ABA was one of the most over
represented terms in normal wild type
tissues for those rnas that were nated
and so that said made us think oh well
that's pretty interesting so what
happens then to the pool of nated rnas
in both wild type and dx01 mutant plants
if now you look at NAD before and after
a treatment and this is 4 hours of ABA
treatment and then we take the RNA pools
and then we do our our pull down and
sequencing and so what you can see is
obviously there is a collection of rnas
that are added both before and after but
we can find a huge collection or at
least 600 almost 600 transcripts in Wild
type and over a thousand almost 1100 um
in the absence of dx01 function that are
added only before treatment these then
don't show that same natation or the NAD
on the th Prime end after treatment and
now we find a whole new collection
of molecules that are actually nated
specifically during Ava treatment that
were not nated before Ava treatment and
so what I'm going to show you is the
first thing that we decided to do is
figure out is adding a adad stabilizing
destabilizing or are rna's agnostic to
having that that molecule on them and so
what I'm going to tell you is this was
an approach I developed as a
postto I never knew how wonderfully
useful it was going to be I literally
just did it to say that if you didn't
have a five Prime cap in plant
transcripton you're were going to be
turned into small Ras but what we found
is this is what we call GMU or
genomewide mapping of UNCA cleave
transcripts I didn't know it at the time
but U Mike
Axel developed a similar approach he
called it Deone sequencing Blake Meers
and Pam green developed a similar
approach they called it pair my name was
way too many words and way too
complicated and so pair is what you guys
call it today basically or what most
people call it either that or deom seek
but GMU is actually basically the same
thing as degrom seek or or pair the one
thing that's different is they actually
put in their initial Library prep they
put a restriction enzyme finding site
into their five Prime adapter and so
their reads are all very very short
inserts we figured out a way now more
recently whereby you just put on the
five Prime adapter so it's five Prime
race it's genome wide five Prime race
where you put on a five Prime adapter
and then you select three prime ends
randomly by basically just using an RT
primer that's a a random hexamer
attached to the three prime alumina
adapter and we can now make these
libraries in a day time from beginning
to end and you have five Prime race and
so what I can tell you is you can use
this approach to look at endonucleolytic
cleavage I'll show you some evidence to
to show that m6a actually inhibits
endonucleolytic cleavage in a rabit
opsis I'm going to show you how we use
it as a quick and dirty mechanism to
look at are you more degraded or less
degraded like in with ABA or without ABA
or with NAD or with without NAD and I'll
show you how we use it that way and we
also found that there's a co-
transational Decay pathway that
functions in plants and so we can
actually use this approach now to also
look at translational Dynamics and
plants and also to look at the
transcripts specifically that are
degraded co-translationally um I don't
think I'm going to have time to show you
any of that data but I'm happy to to
talk to anybody about that if they're
interested in it okay so what we
actually found is this this proportion
uncapped metric it's just a quick and
dirty measure such that we don't have to
treat with transcription Inhibitors
every time we can actually just correct
GMU read total libraries for a
transcript over the amount of reads that
we see from Mr seek as long as you take
the same sample do GMU on half do AR
seek on the other half and then you can
use this just correction to give a if we
have higher proportion on cap metric
that means in that condition those rnas
were more degraded if we lower that
metric then in those conditions that
rnas were less degraded okay and so what
I'm going to show you is in fact we use
this metric for not capped rnas that
were only capped in
control capped in both conditions are
capped only in Ava conditions to show in
fact and we did this multiple times in
multiple different conditions to show
that that mad molecule being added to
the five Prime and of transcripts is an
incredibly destabilizing Moy and this is
exactly what this type of data then
looked like like I said we have these
those transcripts that were only naate
control in both conditions and only
those in ABA and so what you would
expect is if it's a destabilizing mark
because what we're doing here is we're
correcting that proportion on cap metric
in the ABA samples so what we should see
is that metric rise when you add it in
the ABA samples when you're comparing
Ava to control we should actually see
that metric decrease in the the ones
that are only Ned and control because
now in the AV conditions which are in
the numerator we should have no NAD
being left and only the NAD being left
in the control so the higher G um
proportion on cap would be here versus
here in this case the higher proportion
on cap is here versus here so we see an
increase and those shares were centered
right on zero whether it was in wildad
conditions or those dxo one-2 mutant
conditions and so what this told us in
fact was yes this moyy is in fact an
incredibly destabilizing moyy when it's
added the five Prime end and so when you
do have it you're going to destabilize
those rnas when you remove it now you're
going to stabilize them so this pool
becomes stabilized in the context of
adaa so then we were interested to just
kind of say what type of go or what type
of transcripts do we actually see with
that mad molecule in the control
conditions versus after ABA treatment
and this is what we're hoping to see and
thankfully this is exactly what we saw
so what these plants are doing is
actually using that NAD molecule on the
five Prime end to destabilize those
trans transcripts when you don't want
them around then they remove it either
through transcription or just or
removing it and then recapping which
does happen in plants on the side of
plasm I might add and then in this
condition now we found that these
Regulators were now not added and were
actually stabilized such that you can
make the protein and get proper ABA
response and so I can tell you this is
exactly what it was we took we've went
and looked at some of these important
Regulators don't worry about what's
going on in dx01 dx01 is incredibly ABA
and sensitive and this is exactly why is
because those Regulators are not
properly regulated but for instance the
master regulator Master one of the
master Regulators of the ABA response
ABA abi5 is kned in control conditions
and no longer kned when you treat with
that ABA response and what I can show
you then is when you can go through and
specifically validate this doing the NAD
versus the the NAD versus the non-n NAD
fraction in control versus ABA in both
Colombia and dx01 and we could show that
when the cap is on there they're
stabilized when you remove that cap they
actually now become stabilized they stay
around and they actually make the
protein to get you proper Ava response
they to this model right here whereby
sorry in those control conditions right
you have the NAD on there you Dad and in
fact this enzyme pryc is involved in the
Decay as well so you keep those rnas at
low levels such that you don't have ABA
response when you don't want it when you
add that hormone ABA and you want to
have proper AA response you actually add
the right cap either through
transcription of new stuff and proper
capping or by removing the NAD cap and
recapping on the cytoplasm that's what
we're working on right now this then
inhibits the dading and the Decay and so
now you make protein you get proper AA
response so this is what we're working
on in the context of of mad capping and
like I said we're very interested in how
it's added how it's controlled and also
looking at other things involved um in
this dading process in the context of
Ava response right now
so I've talked to you about a five Prime
modification and how this is a
destabilizing Moy the modification that
actually got us thinking about this
feature in RNA molecules themselves was
actually this one down here this
specific internal modification which to
date is the most abundant internal mRNA
modification that we know about
specifically m6a and I will say once
again melean systems were characterizing
this over and over and over again but
there actually hadn't been a very good
study about what the what the function
of this modification was and plants when
we first started down this road so we
collaborated with rert Frey and before I
get there I just want to remind you that
because work has been done on this
system there's a lot more there's even
more known about it right we know that
this is exactly what adamine looks like
we know the entire complex of proteins
now that's involved in writing there's
actually two of them the one I'm going
to focus on today is the major one it's
driven by MTA which is the orthologue of
metal 3 um in humans which is the major
me transfer in humans so we know what
writes it or adds it to the ad molecule
we know what erases it and I'm going to
talk a little bit about these erasers
down here because if you think about it
there's two ways to make a
hypomethylation type of state within a
plant transcriptome you can either knock
out a writer which would then get rid of
this modification or you can overexpress
an eraser and thereby that also would
remove more in the 6A than you might
want to and so I'm bringing this up
mainly because I'm going to show you
knocking out writers many times but in
our most recent study where we were
looking at pathogen response we actually
used both of these strategies knocking
out parts of the wrer complex as well as
overexpressing erasers to get at what
truly hypo methylation looks like in the
context of pathogen defense response
don't worry I'm going to show you far
less data moving forward and get just
more to models because a lot of this has
been published for a long time um that's
why I can move through a lot of projects
moving forward here now very very
quickly and I will tell you we're also
working on some of the readers the
readers that we're most interested in
are those that are stress responsive
specifically show increase in abundance
during specific stress responses um and
the one that's ones that we're working
on look like are the ones that are up
regulated um in the context of bacterial
or biotic stress response specifically
during bacterial infection and I have a
a graduate student postdoc where for
those but I'm not going to talk about
that today so when we first got into
this game we have to get past the fact
that m6a or methylation of adamine at
the sixth position is a fundamentally
important modification in plants and
animals if you knock out those rder
proteins You Are embryonic lethal so the
plants are dead at their embryonic stage
and you can't really characterize them
so thankfully Rupert had been working on
this for a few years before we got
interested in this this thing in this
modification and so he had developed
this 50y little plant line down here
where your homozygous knock out for MTA
but we can get past that embryonic
lethality by expressing MTA under an
embryonic specific promoter thereby
getting us past that block and then we
can get into development and depending
on the levels of m6a that you allow left
these plants don't look normal this is
probably the best picture we ever took
at one of these things but you can
already see they're smaller they're
purple and I can tell you really when
you grow them on soil they look very
very sick so this is a very nice system
and it's we can get the levels very very
low and specifically we started looking
Leaf tissue because we could keep the
levels of m6a lowest in that specific
tissue so first question was is this a
stabilizing or destabilizing Moy so once
again this is where we first started
using that trick of using gmox our
specific our five Prime race protocol
with the with the correction to show
right that that um that we can use this
as a quick and dirty approach to look at
RNA stability um we also then developed
m6a pull down we weren't the first one
to do it we just modified it so that it
worked well in plant transcripton
specifically we're using an m6a specific
antibody to pull down those methylated
regions and do high throughput
sequencing plant transcriptomes to show
that and then we and others had showed
right that this occurs mostly in the
three prime utr and around stop codons
if you want to see what the patterns of
methylation look like you can read any
other paper but what we were interested
in saying is is it stabilizing or
destabilizing so once again we used wild
type versus MTA plants because basically
based on what will happen in these if we
see in the m6a deficient um types of
transcripts they become more or less
abundant in the CA and versus wild type
if you look specifically with
transcripts that have m6a sites versus
all other transcripts that aren't m68 at
least in our data site here what we
found is in fact when you Mo knock out
the major methyl transfer R these
transcripts then become destabilized
specifically those methylated
transcripts become destabilized in the
absence of methylation as compar
compared to when the methylation was
present so unlike NAD now what we were
seeing was that m6a was a St utilizing
myyy and so I'm happy to report that we
weren't wrong and many many other groups
have gone on and and been seeing the
same thing in the context of many other
different plant responses and in fact
the human people realized that they
weren't analyzing their data wrong they
were analyzing their data wrong and in
fact m6a unlike earlier reports is a
stabilizing Moy also in in in animals
and why was it a why is it a stabilizing
Moy well what we found is when you go
back to that g up data like I said we
can also look at endonucleolytic
cleavage what in fact we found was if
you look in m6a and you look four to
five nucleotides Upstream of the site
within the motif there was methalated in
our Peaks we can in fact see that this
methylation event tended to be four to
five nucleotides Downstream of a very
strong cleavage site that we can map by
looking at the very five Prime end of
our gup reads that's the most
informative nucleotide in all of GM
because it tells you right where the
cleavage event occurred and we could say
we see a cleavage event in this thing
and now we see that the methylation site
is fortified nucleotides Downstream and
when it's gone in those m6a deficient
mutants specifically in MTA mutants now
what happens is that methylation event
is gone because they're in6 a deficient
you get an uclear
cleavage we now know what this is in
humans and most likely the same orthol
in Plants does this types of cleavage
and then you get clearing of these
intermediates by xrn4 and most likely
the exosome once this cleavage occurs
because you've lost that mulation event
okay so this happens both in plants and
humans how m6a is stabilizing is
basically when it's there as inhibiting
an endonuclear cleavage event fortifi
nucleotides Upstream of that methylated
a so when you get rid of the m6a now you
get the cleavage and then you get
turnover of those
rnas
so I can tell you in the context of this
study what we also started to look at
was is this type of methylation event
does it have physiological re relevance
okay and so what we first started
working on and I'm going to show you now
three different abiotic stresses we
first started looking at a abiotic
stress to say is m6a important do we
need it there to get proper response to
Salt cold and he more recently heat I'm
going to show you no data for heat I'm
going to show you some data for salt and
going to show you some data for cold and
then I'm going to show you some bio some
data for biotic stress as well and then
I'll be done with inet as well so what
we've actually turned to looking at was
when we looked at methyl methylated salt
stress response en coding protein mrnas
what we found in fact is when you had
methylation events in their three prime
utr we also saw changes in secondary
structure so in fact the methylation
event was there to decrease secondary
structure and specific specifically when
you it was only these specific salt
stress responsive transcripts that
showed this change both in having
methylation now in salt stress and the
structural change and not any other type
of transcripts then that led to
increased sorry really screwing up with
this this this this um pointer here it
was only these transcripts specifically
that were methylated with a structural
change this showed increased protein
output in the context of solid stress
response and so it led to this specific
model here whereby that methylation
event had to be there to most likely
unravel a structure because it's a
structure busting type of muy if that
structure was forming this was most
likely what was recruiting that
endonuclear enzyme giving you cleavage
leading to turnover and destabilization
then if you wanted to have proper self
stress response what happened is you
methylated these transcripts encoding
the proteins involved in s stress
response we inhibit then the the recruit
of this this cleavage enzyme stabilizing
these mrnas and it's only these ones
that also change the secondary structure
that led the increased protein output
from these salt stress response
Regulators giving us proper salt stress
response so because I talked about
structure I'm just going to tell you one
other little vignette two slides I
promise you here mainly because we have
used structure data in the context of
hypomethylation once again in those MTA
mutants as compared it in normal
methylation to show that you have to
have proper methylation of primary
primary micr transcripts if you don't
have proper methylation of these
transcripts they fold into weirdo types
of secondary structures that we could
make models for using our databased
approach and thereby if you don't make
the proper stem Loop you obviously don't
cleave out the micr RNA and so then you
also don't have proper micro biogenesis
so then that's what you see can see here
basically you need proper methylation to
get the proper stem Loop folding and if
you don't have the proper stem Loop then
you don't recruit the biogenesis
machinery and you are deficient in
specific classes of of micras based on
this type of structure and revelation of
the data that we've made okay so as I
told you we had done one atic stress
specifically salt so we next turned our
attention to whether other abiotic
stresses could also um be involved or
whether m6a could be involved in other
atic stresses specifically now we
treated with cold for 24 hours once
again what we did here is we looked for
cold specific Peaks versus Peaks that we
didn't we only saw in control conditions
and we did shared Peaks and what we
found specifically is when you looked at
transcripts that were methylated only in
cold and showed an upregulation of their
mRNA abundance now that's where we found
those cold response protein and coding
transcripts there're specifically
methylated and upregulated in response
to cold and they were found in this this
transcript here this is is the only this
is this can be shown here whereby when
you look at cold andrich this is just
for mRNA abundance here when you look at
Cold andrich Peaks versus cold enrich
Peak control enrich Peaks and shared
what we can see is that these become
stabilized specifically pathway is
stabilized specifically in the context
of cold response as compared to those
controll conditions you can see once
again there's no movement and no Shar
because they are methalated both in the
context of control and cold conditions
we also decided to say because we didn't
see any changes in RNA stability I'm
cutting out all of that data so we did
some ribosome profiling to say is there
an effect then on the level of
translation from these specific cold
stress response encoding proteins since
I'm showing you the data the answer to
this question was obviously yes and you
can see that data over here specifically
those cold enriched and increased
abundance transcripts were more ribosome
enriched or more ribosome bound and gave
us higher translational efficiency as
compared to those that lost methylation
or had methylation both before and after
cold treatment and so what this told us
once again is in the context of cold
instead of inhibiting cleavage now what
you were doing is this methylation event
was somehow increasing the protein or
the the the the translation of these
mrnas and we're still looking at how
methylation is doing this because unlike
in animal systems which I don't believe
that data as well they said that if you
methylate here at the five Prime utr we
saw no five Prime utr
okay they said that the methylation
event could actually recruit the
translation Machinery itself we don't
have any evidence for that right now we
actually think that what this
methylation event is doing is it's still
here in the three prime because that's
where we see all these cold specific
Peaks we think it's actually helping to
just cause a circularization and then
the function the basically just keeping
those rols better equipped through the
yth proteins being bound to this
specific this this this specific
manipulation event but I don't have time
to show you evidence for that today okay
so I've shown you that we can see that
m6a is important for Sal stress response
F stress response and what I can tell
you is we're about to publish on plant
heat stress response which looks very
very similar to the Salt stress response
whereby it becomes a stabilizing moyy
whereby there thereby increasing
Half-Life which I'm going to show you is
also the case and biotic stressy spots
so far only cold is where we see this
translation phenotype and so this is a
pretty stress that we're continuing on
for that that that translation effect so
once again I just want to remind you
that you can make hypomethylation by
knocking out riter components or by
overexpressing eraser
components and I'm just telling you this
mainly because we used both types of of
either mutants or overexpressors to show
that it's not just the phenotype of the
Eraser mutants because they're small and
they're weird these plants look very
very normal noral when we just
overexpress one of these erasers even
though they're hypermethylated but we
can still see that they have the exact
same pathogen defense response defects
which I'll show you here in a second
okay so first of all what we found and
this is how we got into this game was
when we just looked at bulk m6a and we
treated with either bacteria or mimicked
bacterial infection by treating with
with the flag 22 peptide which is the 22
amino acid peptide of felin which is one
of the the potent signaling molecules
that plants are looking at what we found
was that there was a large scale
rearrangement of the m6a in in very very
quickly in response to either pathogen
infection and or flag 22 treatment and
then that was corrected by 24 hours of
either infection or a little bit later
on after flag after flag treatment so
spans were basically wiping their m6a
transcriptome and then putting it back
on a little bit later um and so what we
decided to do here once again in the
context of two different ways this in
this case I'm just showing you the data
for overexpressing one of those eraser
proteins we also also looked at
hypomethylation and MTA and found that
many of these transcripts that were
hypomethylated either in the MTA mutant
Andor in the overexpression of that
eraser overlapped both in control and in
flag 22 um basically mimicking uh
bacterial response and what in fact we
found was the things that tended to be
misregulated before or in control
conditions as compared to after flag 22
treatment e in either of these
hypomethylated conditions had to do with
response to bacteria response to fungus
and response to biotic biotic pathogens
and so we were very we were continuing
down this way what I'm going to tell you
is kind of skip over a whole bunch of
other experiments to tell you what we
found was using GMU once again it was
stabilizing defense respon encoding
protein defense defense protein response
encoding transcripts and so we just
validated some of these things using the
the common way of inhibiting
transcription which is why I like our
GMU approach better because these type
of of experiments are incredibly labor
intensive you get data for one
transcript at a time but this is exactly
the data here whereby when you have a
hypo methylation event these Regulators
are actually then destabilized in the in
the absence of methylation when they
should be much more long lived when you
treat with 522 um for these specific
defense response Regulators that we
actually showing you here and so just to
show you some physiological relevant
data here what you can see is both in
the context of a methylation mutant so
this is the methyl transferase we can
make the mutant there what you can see
is they're actually resistant they're
more resistant to both pathogens as well
as they don't show this growth this
growth inhibition when treated with that
flag 22 peptide and they are also more
resistant to different bacteria as well
as if you treat with a fungal pathogen
so in this case getting rid of the
methyl transferases and or
overexpressing this this eraser
protein and making a hypomethylation
event makes you actually more resistant
to a biotic specifically a bacterial
pathogen and or treatment with this flag
22 peptide and so we're very very
interested in this result right here
especially mainly because I didn't have
time to show you this today but these
plants actually are slightly bigger than
wild type they develop slightly faster
and they are more resistant to bacterial
and fungal pathogens so we think in fact
this type of hypomethylation event might
actually be good um for from a crop
Improvement perspective and so we're
going to try and put this into other
plant species and actually test this um
in a relevant crop species and so what I
hope I've convinced you of today is that
m6a is an important post trans ntional
regulator of both plant abiotic and
biotic stress responses and we're
continuing to work on this on the
context um of of the Eraser proteins in
the context of biotic stress response as
well um I have five more minutes I
believe for this talk and so I'm just
going to tell you very very quickly
because we're actually collaborating now
with Andrew on this last little vignette
that I'm going to show you here and I
just want to remind you based on this
slide that I've talked to you about a
lot of data for this cyer 5 Prime cap uh
non-canonical modification on the cap
structure I've talked to you about this
one modification here and you can see
how important these two modifications
are but just to remind you right there
is an incredible collection of
modifications so out there to be
characterized and looked at most likely
from a lot of different physiological
types
perspectives and pulling down one and
sequencing one in a specific type of
Developmental and oror pathogen Andor
stress context is incredibly labor
intensive and it's going to take a lot
of work from a lot of different um
investigators to actually do this type
of work plus you have to use a very
specific type of antibody or chemistry
to specifically turn NAD into Biotin and
there's a lot of work to look at one
modification in one type of of
perspective and so to be quite honest
this was our first project in
modifications then we got really
interested in m6a and then we got like I
said we were working on NAD for eight
years and finally figured out that it
was dading that was important in the
context of the dx1 mutants but what we
had also thought about was can we come
up with a much quicker way to find
modification sites that does not require
pull down does not require any type of
fancy antibody based sequencing approach
and nicely for us RT specifically
non-error correcting RTS reverse
transcriptases do Nature's work for us
specifically when they find
modifications that affect the Watson
cric based pairing Edge that is the
chemical information they're using to
put in the base at that specific
nucleotide such that then when they see
one of these modifications that affects
those three positions in GC based Pairs
and those two positions in at so it's
about 45 modifications now if they don't
error correct you can just go through
any type of RNA seek data set looking
for these types of sites specifically
mismatches or sequencing errors at those
sites and you can find modification
sites and we call this algorithm hammer
or highr annotation of modified
ribonucleotides we've done it on small R
we've done it on GM we've done it on RNA
seek and this is exactly what it looks
like whereby it's a g and you can see a
pile up specifically of misincorporated
bases there and we can call that site
then a two methyl guanas SC right or an
m2g site um and we can see about 45 of
these specific as long as they affect
that wats and cck based pairing Edge and
because these mutations are actually
semi-
random m2g you get a very specific
collection of those of those those base
mismatches same thing for M1A we can
actually kind of subcategorize them into
about 10 different groups such that we
can turn five mod 45 modifications into
different 10 different subgroups and do
this just going back and reannotating
now all the RNA seek data sets from
every different crop species and this is
exactly what we're working on with the
banre right now I didn't have time to
show you any of this data but this is
the question that we are also interested
in asking with this project specifically
because when we when we did this
approach in a rabid opsis what we found
in fact is that modifications tended to
be found much much more often in the Guk
Library when we just looked at these
types of modifications as compared to
normal Mr seek Library
and so what it looks like in fact is
that the the pool of degrading rnas gets
Modified by this type of modification it
affects this Waton cck based pairing
Edge as they're being degraded such that
they can no never be translated ever
again and they just go into the
degrading pool and so we're trying to
answer this from an evolutionary
perspective with answer
currently so once again using this
algorithm now just analyzing any RNA SE
data set we can get about 45
modifications sorry say doesn't work
because it's not it's at the sixth
position it's not one of those three POS
or the two positions in a& that affects
that Watson cck based paing Edge but at
least we have an approach to get it that
and we can't look at in modifications I
should say so once again we're stuck
with NAD you have to pull that down and
see it's just that okay and with that um
I just want to cite the people in my lab
these are the current members in my lab
up here um Lisa and uh will are two
great graduate students I have two great
posts wrong is is still a graduate
student a great group um of undergrads
and I just found out that I left Will's
name off there will prowl was the one
who did all of the work on the biotic
stress responses um I also cited down
here all the previous lab members whose
data I talked about from a publish
perspective the Crusty lab and these
these G these peeps here were helped us
with the aoic stress response and are
now working with Will on the D
methylases and all of my funding so far
is come from NSF both MCB and iOS and
Will was supported by a full bright
scholarship and with that I'm going to
stop and I'm happy to take your
questions
thank
yes yeah you show picture of
the and I'm
interested
yeah so pseudo that's pseudo uation
right um and yes so pseudo uation
thankfully we can see it by Hammer um
and I have it's definitely there in
specific
mrnas we're right now because we found
in specific context we can actually
increase the amount of pseudo reation we
can see in specific mras I didn't have
time to talk about it today and so now
we're actually going back and using some
of our structure sequencing approach is
because it's always been said that
that's a structure stabilizing Moy and
we want to see is it structure
stabilizing and do you have to structure
stabilize to actually see the the
importance of it so yes it's a great
question yes it's imp plant transcripton
yes we think it's important but I can't
convince you of that yet today so I just
didn't put in my
talk Mar so
yourx X1 you're seeing um basically
phase small production as the
degradation
correct do you see a role for in
functional production so I have asked
Blake to look um and I'm sure he's he's
looking um he hasn't gotten back to me
on that but I mean he's the phy he's a
phy guru so I I did not want to touch
anything to do with that but I told him
you know I I showed him this data a
while ago so I I think he's he's well on
it um I made I was reviewing I was
review reviewing I think one of Keith
slins like papers and he was talking
about this and we had just published
this I'm like you should speculate to
remind Blake and so he put heed the
paper and like speculated is this
involved in phy so great question yeah
at the same one um I'm gonna avoid
Andrews because I saw your hand up first
so question
about those Ava biosynthetic genes or
they response genes
and kind of running the risk of over
interpreting but terms of the
other6 salth all
things lifestyle be influenced by a so
am I like over interpreting or is there
some very specific effect of
modifications um so I can tell you we
have not looked at Aba the context of
m6a um my guess is yes there would be
some effects on that as well just
because m6a marks all these things and
every time we look you kind of wipe it
off of the things and sorry you put it
onto the things you want to stabilize in
that specific condition and that's why
it's a beautiful little Mark right is
because you're adding it
co-transcriptionally we believe I didn't
have time to show you our data for that
but that's one of the major things we're
working on is we do believe it's added
code transcriptionally and we believe
it's the erasers that are selecting the
sites and so that's why will is working
on the erasers right now it's
ventilation is actually happening
everywhere in a transcript if you read
the if you read our biotic stress
response paper you can see the hints
that we were going on specifically when
you knock out the erasers now we start
seeing methylation all throughout the
CDs so we're now learning how to purify
and sequence nent transcript so we can
show that in the context of the Eraser
mutants is happening cotranscriptionally
that's the last thing we're doing right
now now but um we think it will affect
ABA we don't know we haven't checked for
NAD capping in the context of other
stress responses that's actually part of
a grant I'm writing right now um mainly
because we do want to look because it
does look to be such a potent
destabilizer but please remember what we
think is going to happen then is NAD is
going to have the opposite effect so
growth Regulators are the things that
are now going to get nated for instance
in the context of stress response
because we know those become
destabilized right right so we think
that the growth Regulators in the
context of pathogen infection are going
to get nated and destabilized whereas
the things encoding the pathogen
response proteins and I just showed you
this get methylated and now they're
stabilized so we think it's these two
modifications are actually going to
interplay off each other to give you
that switch between growth growth and uh
and stress response that's a great
question this is exactly where we're
heading in thinking in that in that
regard great
question so I think you might have just
answered our something that was eating
at me through your the NAD part of your
talk um seems like uh turn you know
preventing turnover sounds very
waste right but it sounds like you were
just saying that nading is actually a
regulatory in your your mind or maybe in
your test tubs uh is actually a
regulatory mechanism and uh so I should
be thinking of it as a turnover as being
the thing that's regulated rather then
wasting all this
RNA and to nucleotides and Al
nucleotides yeah and then turning that
off right I think I think that's yeah
think about it from a degradation
perspective sorry don't think about it
from
wasting yeah that's how I don't think
about it from the Wast of nucleares
perspective
Andrew it's not a PL question but um I
was I was curious about the the the
difference in response m6a and the bi
abiotic stress versus m6a and biotic
stress and I was wondering the biotic
stress
that's no I mean so if you this is based
on not work that we've done in my lab
it's the viral right it's the viral work
from from other labs whereby viruses
actually use the plant's m6a Machinery
against them because they take the
Machinery methylate their transcripts
stabilize their transcripts and then
that allows them to basically take over
the plant cell so you know this this
modification there's there's an arms
race there too right and we do think
that there's going to be some sort of
sensing mechanism that's why we're
getting more interested in that that cap
methylation event we're thinking that
there's going to be some some arms race
both with m6a and that methylation of M7
Rosine that's very very preliminary I
don't have I can't talk more about it
other than just to say there's
definitely an arms race pathogens are
definitely using the methylation
Machinery against plants and animals as
well I mean like everything I talk about
in plants is true in is true in animals
right they have exact same proteins
there's one for one orthologues other
than when it comes to the readers and
then what happened is in plant
transcriptomes I didn't say this but
I'll say it very very quickly plant
transcriptomes have three times as many
readers as compared to the animal
systems like a rabit opsis has 12 humans
have five right so and then there's
other plants that have up to 18 or 20 so
usually there's about three times as
many readers and plants because they're
probably sub functionalizing readers to
specific stress responses and we see
that in arms so thank
you oh uh I'll take one more question
one more
question this is a followup through
qu so in terms of biotic stress yes
you're seeing effects on bacteria but
also increased resistance to fungal
pathogens you know that's somewhat
surprising right because often those are
are kind of play off each
other
or so does that tell you something about
the
guys no we were surprised um because you
know they show all the the plants show
all the classical har Hallmarks of
bacterial resistance but then if treat
them with so we didn't think they were
going to be Fung more fungally resistant
and then they were so we're extremely
surprised we're like combing back
through all of our data right now to
like figure out how it is and what it
looks like is it's probably a couple of
transcription factors are going the same
way right to then upregulate both
responses the proper way and that's how
they're more resistant so I mean like I
said we need to do a lot more work on
that overexpression of the Eraser
because if it truly does make them more
pathogen resistant not just weirdo or
Rabbid offis right in a perfect
condition but like if we can move that
into the field then that's great that's
great this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu